Today, we're going to show you acid rain.
This used to be a huge environmental problem.
We're going to demonstrate it to you in the lab.
And we're going to do it with a piece of kit,
which I inherited from my late friend, David Jones.
We got the kit, but not the instructions,
but Neil worked out how to use it.
The problem of acid rain is that in the
1960s, 1970s,
people were burning fuel, particularly cold.
That contained a lot of sulfur.
They were burning it in their homes in power stations.
And even at one time in trains,
in railway locomotives,
and when the sulfur containing coal burns,
it generates [inaudible], which is a gas and sometimes [inaudible]
, which is a solid, but it's generated as fine particles in the air. And then when it rains, these gas,
[inaudible]
dissolve in the water to give either self euros or
sulfuric acid acid.
Rain has caused huge environmental problems,
particularly killing forests because trees like
pine trees and so on, normally do not grow on very acid soil.
And we're talking about really quite acidic rain on the East coast of the
United States.
Some of the acid rain had an acidity or pH between that of lemon
juice and battery acid.
So the experiment consists of a large container in which
you can burn sulfur
To generate the SOA two or three.
It then has a vessel on top in which you can put water in and the
water is sprayed out of some class arms.
So you get rain going into the gas. The problem is,
of course you can't see whether the water has become acidic.
If you just use plain water.
So you have to put in indicator,
He added a tiny bit of potassium hydroxide, which made it nice blue color.
And if it goes acidic.
Right.
Run number one, Neil was unduly modest,
put in just a little bit of sulfur.
Wasn't enough,
[inaudible].
It rained, but no acid. So next time,
Neil, let himself go and put in a large amount of sulfur.
It burnt well. In fact, it caused fog inside the container.
That's rather interesting because when people burnt coal with sulfur in it,
we used to get terrible smokes.
People couldn't see their feet when they were basically because the smoke was so
thick.
[Inaudible].
The experiment then worked really nicely.
You could see the water going down, forming raindrops,
and as the drops fell, they went from blue to red.
Brady was quite courageous. He puts his camera in the water.
[Inaudible].
You can see the rain drops coming down and eventually it was drought.
We really liked the demonstration.
And I think the important thing to know about acid rain is that
it was a huge environmental problem,
but it is one which chemists and engineers have
succeeded in more or less solving
domestic fires.
These are heating in houses now uses coal,
which has had the sulfur removed and the large power stations.
They take the flue gas that comes out of the boilers
and diesel fries.
It usually by reacting it with lime,
the Sr two reacts with the lime to make calcium sulfate,
which is innocuous.
It can just be put to landfill nowadays,
most power station, certainly here in the UK,
use natural gas methane rather than cuddle.
So the amount of limestone that is being used for desulfurization
is going down for is substantially.
But if you went out for a stroll in that romantic looking mist,
hanging over the trees around the Lake,
the chances are that you would be breathing in a dilute form of sulfuric acid.
Acid.
Rain was not a big issue here in the UK because
most of the [inaudible] was injected quite high in the atmosphere and blown
over to mainland Europe where there's much more forest than in the UK.
Tall chimneys throws sulfur latent, exhaust high into the air.
And it had really quite significant effects.
And the forest in Germany and Northern Europe.
It comes from verbals Eastern and Western Europe,
but due to the prevailing winds,
maybe around 50% comes from great Britain.
I first came to Nottingham on some days you could taste the
[inaudible] in the air.
The removal of the [inaudible] has had one quite strange effect that
Nottingham was famous for growing roses.
And it turned out that the [inaudible] in the air was very good at tilling
the,
some of the mildew and other pests that can grow on roses.
So when the air was cleaned up, the roses started to getting all of these pests.
And now the Rose growing industry round Nottingham has more or less
disappeared.
Would you like to learn more about raindrops? How about the shape of raindrops?
Our sister channel all about physics 60 symbols. Has you covered on that one?
Also you to everyone who supports.
Periodic videos on Patrion, you can see those names on the screen at the moment.
If you'd like to join them and pick your element,
go to patrion.com/periodic videos.